so let's go back to the aftermath days I
think a lot of people just like that's
the time a hip hop where everyone was
like man that was the golden era was
when all that was going on what is like
the number one member you have of
working there with Dre and kind of all
the work that they were doing the number
one memory was I had an eagle out of
control I've never changed I think my
mom has said this last year she said you
never changed if anything you've
polished some areas you know you always
had confidence and money never changed
you it enhanced you know certain things
about you but that period your life you
were definitely a piece of [ __ ]
my mom saying this right she was very
proud of me but at the same time like
you know like this was embarrassing
because you know Koreans you know they
want you to be a doctor lawyer blah blah
I'm like look man like I said the worst
job in Vietnam me not friends I mean my
attorney in my head and my doctor great
people but um II go out of control I'm
making $150,000 a year and the I'm
starting to see checks like I wasn't
getting this $55 a month paycheck that's
you know after taxes and everything else
blah blah whatever you pay tracks and
things I was getting bonuses and points
and things like that you know numbered
rep Dre wrote me a really big check I've
never had a check like I've never had a
six-figure check in my entire lives and
he pulls me to the side and he says a
man making a million dollars is easy
keeping it is not and I was like make a
million I thought even then I'm 24 I
thought once you become a millionaire
you stand doing it air I didn't know you
know I you know why would I know
so pulls me aside and he bought everyone
an expedition this was like the hottest
this was the hottest SUV out and there
wasn't a ton people when he bought like
you know the eight guys expeditions and
he bought like three or four girls
Explorer's I worked in the company and I
was like yellow dope and everyone got
their checks
these guys make more money because they
had points their producers and their
artists and stuff but you know it pulls
me to the side he was what you can do
with the money and I'm like why are you
asking me that's [ __ ] up did you how
did you ask them did you ask button did
you ask Mellon to ask Chris like you
know white white white [ __ ] me and you
because you're my agent man you know
what I think you have more potential you
know like what are you gonna do them I
don't know man you know I mean Brian
never had money before you know what I'm
gonna do you like I want to get her side
she show you those okay get them Versace
shirt we gonna do I don't know cause man
look man don't be an n-word and I was
like what and I was like man okay
whatever you know it was I really wasn't
paying attention I was focused on going
to the BMW dealership said she west BMW
it was in the back of my mind I just had
to go and he was like man listen man
just be smart
no okay fine I go straight to century
West BMW I go buy an m3 left there I was
there an hour and a half to a paper but
I left there I go to this play called
juniors jewelers and Sherman Oaks and I
buy a Rolex with diamonds in it
I come back to the studio to the studio
our hours are different drill work till
3:00 4:00 in the morning to him you know
so I go back to aftermath studios and I
pull up in the car and everything else I
don't say anything so I want gray to be
mad right the dude who runs a studio
it's also drains like right-hand man he
tells me what's going on a man this one
here this this and we have a ton of
security because you can't just go in
there we have cars everything so it
starts going around the studio a man
been balling yo man then yeah you know
been been you hang and dump all I'm a
yolk she bought this Pinto Joshy got
chrome wheels man just a bus oh man just
[ __ ] man he went and did this
and so from what I heard Dre got up like
literally out of his seat they said he
got a beat is to being made like he's
making a beat but he said he got like
half way instead making a song stops it
walks out of Studio B walks into the
kitchen I'm making a throws me sandwich
with all this extra man cinema Bob
Loggins like the repartee goes oh you
have a nice sandwich I'm like yeah tre
how's ADR man what's up man and he goes
so what's up man
which do today and I was like oh man you
know I was like I never had a rule
that's before you know so like you know
boom he goes nice Watchmen
it's nice Watchmen you didn't buy
anything else and I was like well I mean
about a couple things like oh you get a
Versace shirt I was like no no I mean
I'll get one this week he goes no you
don't need to get one this week doesn't
ribose because that's your [ __ ]
black BMW out there on chrome wheels and
everything else and I was like man I I
wanted a nice car you because you have a
nice car you know you've got a Lexus and
you have an expedition most people at
your age don't even have two cars little
another 31 oh I'm selling Alexis and he
goes and he didn't speak to me for
almost a month
I was probably my most memorable moment
one of the most memorable moments and he
was just disgusted with me now the funny
thing was all that money went
swell left after meant I had no money I
was broke I